something that we really like and some
we enjoy and every day we do soul food
you gotta when you say soul food that
means that take us years and years back
with children pig feet meatloaf all that
that take us way back I mean years years
of back My Generation my mother
generates my mother's mother generation
so soul food is something that everybody
loves and everybody wants can't get
enough of it
foreign
chicken wings
garlic bread
and Tall spring salad
we got candy items
we got red beans and rice
I'm gonna share the red beans and rice
amazing rice
we got collard greens
[Music]
mac and cheese
he has the best the best
Jerry is a very nice person easy going
and please don't tell him about his
cooking he know it's good
they go so bad
everybody's welcome to come to Jerry's
down home kitchen we got breakfast lunch
and dinner salmon go cats fish and grits
fried pork chops I smell the potato home
fries uh Chicken and Waffles so we would
love to have you coming to you I love